♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WITH THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS APPROACHING, SUDDENLY
EVERYONE IS ADMITTING THAT
SURGICAL MASKS ACTUALLY DON'T
STOP THE CORONAVIRUS.
IF THEY DID, MAY BE CLOSE TO A
MILLION AMERICANS WOULDN'T HAVE
DIED FROM IT.
EVEN JOE BIDEN AND NANCY PELOSI
HAVE STOPPED PRETENDING, BUT
SOME SCHOOLS HAVEN'T GOTTEN THE
MEMO, THEY ARE STILL FORCING
KIDS TO WEAR MASKS.
NO EXCUSE.
IN ONES TO COME AFFORDED
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS WAS A
PRESS CONFERENCE AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTH FLORIDA.
AT THE HE CAME TO THE PODIUM AND
SAW SEVERAL STUDENTS WEARING
MASKS.
>> YOU DO NOT HAVE TO WEAR THOSE
MASKS, PLEASE TAKE THEM OFF.
IT'S NOT DOING ANYTHING AND WE
HAVE TO STOP WITH HIS COVID
FEAR.
SO IF YOU WANT TO WEAR IT, FINE,
BUT THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
WELL IT IS RIDICULOUS!
AND IF NO ONE ELSE'S GOING TO
TELL THEM, PROBABLY GOOD HE TOLD
THEM.
IT'S NOT GOOD TO LIE TO KIDS.
IT MAKES THEM GROW UP TO BE
LIARS.
AND AS OF COURSE YOU MAY HAVE
NOTICED, THAT ENRAGED THE MEDIA.
THEY WERE TOTALLY INFURIATED BY
THIS BECAUSE IT REFUTED THE LIES
THAT THEY HAVE TOLD FOR YEARS
ABOUT CHILDREN BEING FORCED TO
WEAR MASKS, SO HERE'S HOW THEY
REACTED TO WHAT HE SAID.
>> REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR OF
FLORIDA TODAY, RON DeSANTIS,
BERATING HIGH SCHOOL KIDS FOR
WEARING MASKS AT HIS INDOOR NEWS
CONFERENCE.
>> WHERE WAS THAT GUY?
>> THAT WAS MEAN.
>> I MEAN SERIOUSLY -- WAS THAT
GUY RAISED IN A BARN?
THIS IS A QUESTION I ASKED.
WHO RAISED HIM?
>> THIS IS THE GOVERNOR OF YOUR
STATE, AND IT'S TELEVISED --
LIKE YOU ARE ON VIDEO.
THESE KIDS ARE ALREADY IN AGE
WHERE PEOPLE TEASE AND BULLY AND
YOU SAW THAT GIRL SCRAMBLING TO
TAKE US OFF LIKE WHAT DO I DO.
TO SAY THAT TO A BUNCH OF
MINORS.
>> ONE KID LOOKED AT HIM LIKE
SHUT UP.
THERE WERE SOME KIDS THAT DID
NOT TAKE OFF THE MASK, AND I
THOUGHT THAT'S GOOD PARENTING
RIGHT THERE.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE SUCH
LIARS, THEY WILL SAY ANYTHING
AND IF YOU THINK YOU ARE GAINING
MOMENTUM, THEY WANT TO CRUSH
YOU.
SO JUST TO BE CLEAR, TELLING
KIDS THEY DON'T ACTUALLY HAVE TO
WEAR MASKS BECAUSE MASKS DON'T
WORK WAS BORING BUT THREATENING
TO THROW THEM OUT OF SCHOOL AND
DESTROY THEIR LIVES IF THEY
DON'T WEAR A MASK, SCIENCE.
WE WANT TO STRAIGHTEN US OUT
WITH THE GOVERNOR AFFORDED
HIMSELF.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
SO WHY DID YOU SAY THAT?
GOOD EVENING.
>> WELL, NONE OF THE ADULTS WERE
WEARING MASKS AND IT SEEMED TO
ME THAT SOMEONE TOLD THOSE KIDS
THEY HAD TO DO IT, SO I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE IT VERY CLEAR
THEY DO NOT NEED TO BE DOING IT.
OBVIOUSLY IN FLORIDA IT'S BEEN
A -- IT'S A FREE STATE, YOU CAN
DO IT.
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
POINT OUT THERE IS NO REASON TO
DO IT FOR YOUNG AND HEALTHY
KIDS, ESPECIALLY IN THE STATE OF
FLORIDA.
WE NEVER HAD A MASK MENDED OF
COURSE, BUT OUR GUIDANCE FROM
OUR HEALTH DEPARTMENT IS NOT TO
WEAR THESE CLOTH MASKS, AND I
THINK IT NEEDS TO BE SAID,
BECAUSE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN LIED TO
FOR TWO YEARS, AND SO I WAS -- I
DIDN'T WANT IT TO BE THINKING
THAT THEY WERE TOLD TO DO THIS
BY ME BECAUSE I CERTAINLY
WOULDN'T DO THAT.
AND YOU KNOW, THEY TALK ABOUT
OH, BY LETTING SOMEONE HAVE A
CHOICE TO TAKE OFF THE MASK AND
WELCOMING THAT CHOICE, THAT IS
SOMEHOW BULLYING.
TUCKER, BULLYING IS LOCKING KIDS
OUT OF SCHOOL, WHICH THEY DID.
BULLYING IS FORCING KIDS TO WEAR
MASKS FOR EIGHT HOURS A DAY,
WHICH THEY DID FOR TWO YEARS AND
ARE ONLY STOPPING NOW BECAUSE
THE POLLING HAS CHANGED.
BULLYING IS KICKING PEOPLE OUT
OF WORK BECAUSE OF VACCINE
MANDATES.
WE FOUGHT ALL OF THOSE POLICIES
IN FLORIDA, WE LIFTED PEOPLE UP,
AND WE LIBERATED THEM FROM LOCAL
SCHOOL BOARDS AND GOVERNMENTS
THAT IMPOSED THEM.
>> Tucker: IT'S A LITTLE WEIRD
TO HEAR CRITICISM FROM PEOPLE
WHO ARE UNMASKED SITTING IN
CROWDED STUDIOS SAYING THAT
YOU'RE IMMORAL FOR TELLING KIDS
WHO ARE AT A LOWER RISK THAN THE
ADULTS WHO WERE UNMASKED IN THE
STUDIOS NOT TO WEAR MASKS.
PEOPLE CAN'T SEE THEMSELVES I
GUESS?
>> AND IT CREATES A TWO-TIER
SOCIETY.
YOU HAVE ADULTS THAT ARE NOT
MASKED AND THEN THE STUDENTS ARE
ALL MASKED OR YOU HAVE A CROWDED
RESTAURANT WHERE EVERYONE IS
HAVING A GOOD TIME AND THEY MAKE
THE SERVERS WEAR MASKS.
I REJECT THE TWO-TIER SOCIETY.
I SAY EVERY TIME WE GO WE ARE AT
A BIG EVENT AND THE SERVERS ARE
WEARING IT, THEY SHOULD BE
LIBERATED FROM THOSE MASKS.
IT IS POLITICAL THEATER.
THEY ARE DOING IT FOR THE
APPEARANCE, THEY ARE NOT DOING
IT BECAUSE IT'S HAVING ANY
MEANINGFUL MEDICAL IMPACT.
>> Tucker: BUT EVERYONE LOVES
A CASTE SYSTEM, ESPECIALLY WHEN
THEY ARE AT THE TOP OF IT,
RIGHT?
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE DEMANDING.
>> EXACTLY, AND WE SEEN TIME AND
TIME AGAIN ALL THESE LEFT-WING
LOCKDOWN POLITICIANS, THEY WILL
IMPOSE MANDATES ON OTHERS, AND
THEN THEY WILL BE OUT CAVORTING,
AND BY THE WAY, THEY ESCAPED TO
FLORIDA AND LIVE UNDER OUR
FREEDOM TIME AND TIME AGAIN AND
WE'VE DOCUMENTED THAT AS WELL,
SO IT IS A HIERARCHY, AND THAT'S
WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO IMPOSE
AND WE REJECT THAT IN FLORIDA,
AND YES, IF I HAD PEOPLE THAT I
THINK ARE BEING BULLIED INTO
DOING MASKS, I'M GOING TO LET
THEM KNOW YOU HAVE A RIGHT TO
TAKE IT OFF AND AM ALSO GOING TO
TELL THEM THE TRUTH, WHICH NOT A
LOT OF ADULTS HAVE TOLD THEM,
THAT IT'S NOT EFFECTIVE TO WEAR
THEM IN THE FIRST PLACE.
>> Tucker: AME